Hello Freak bitches.
I also don't understand why it is automatically the guy's fault if it's.
If it's consensual.
I'm not talking about someone being incapacitated.
Blackout drunk.
That's reasonable.
People would see that as an as an assault,
but just if you're both really drunk,
can you have sex?
Why is he the rapist?
Because that tends to be what happens on the campus.
They do blame the young man.
They don't say you raped each other,
that they will take her side.
If she can show they'd had drinks and I find this a.
another strange thing that's happening with feminism today is that it's going
the,
I call it fainting couch feminism.
It's almost as if we're going back to the Victorian era where there was delicate
ladies preyed upon by men and as if the women aren't moral agents.
I mean if you take a lot of drinks a year,
probably have made a decision to lower your inhibitions and be wild or what all
kinds of things are going on that would explain that you're still an agent in
charge of if you're,
you know,
yourself self mastery,
but they deny this of women.
It's all women have no agency and are constantly triggered,
need safe spaces at Brown university,
by the way,
they had to feminists debating.
One of them was a libertarian,
a great Wendy Mackelroy,
and she didn't believe the statistics and another was Jessica Valenti,
hard line feminists.
They were debating,
but that was fine.
It was a debate.
You think that would make everyone happy?
Both sides.
Well-Represented.
No.
The brown feminists were traumatized by the very idea that someone would be
invalidating our experience.
They use that phrase and they ha.
They formed a safe room,
a safe space where you could go,
which had videotapes are frolicking puppies,
coloring books,
bubbles,
stuffed animals,
and this was described in the New York Times,
but it was a cover story in the New York Times magazine by July.
Judith Shula visits and this was the safe space and if you read it and you're,
you're astonished that the of the infantilization puppies,
puppies
frolicking puppies,
say bubbles.
Coloring books.
I get it.
It's kindergarten for college girls.
It hurts my brain.
You know,
this speaks to how people have a hard time accepting some of this new
information.
I have a friend who was a scientist and a the last time you were on,
she said to me,
did you have a climate denier on your show,
a climate change denier?
And I say that he's definitely not denying it,
but some people,
that's all they hear.
When you bring forth a a non mainstream point of view or a controversial
perspective,
instead of considering the possibility,
it almost immediately gets dismissed as this climate change thing is another
ideological struggle.
Yeah,
sure.
Climate change is taking place,
but what are the causes for this?
Are we so sure that it's all caused by human beings?
I would say there's very good reason for humanity to clean up our act in lots of
ways.
Regardless of the issue of climate change.
We're living,
we're abusing mother earth.
We're living upon this planet,
parasites and destroying it.
We thoughtlessly create this gigantic pools of,
of pollution.
We're crazy enough,
insane enough to actually invent nuclear weapons and you know,
long periods of the detonate that bloody things you,
you,
you know,
this is the lots about our behavior that we need to fix because it's right to
fix it philosophically,
right?
We should not behave that way.
We should not behave that way to one another.
We should not behave that way to planet earth.
But to say that we need to fix our behavior because of global warming.
That's an ideological argument and that argument remains to be properly tested.
Yes,
global warming is occurring,
but are we the cause of it or is something else,
some,
some grander scale cosmic effect involved in this?
Well,
we talked about that considerably and I noticed in a lot of the comments from,
from our last discussion,
most of the critical comments where people,
you know,
not liking the idea that I had questioned the dogma of global warming,
but there are some facts that you can't escape the global warming.
Again,
200 years ago,
and we see that the glaciers from the little ice age began to shrink back in the
early 19th century before there was a century before there was any significant
human contract contribution of Sio two to the atmosphere.
So something was driving that warming that began,
and it's important to realize that the little ice age was probably the coldest
period since the end of the great ice age.
In fact,
the data overwhelmingly supports that and that the glaciers grew to the largest
extent around the planet and 10,000 years.
So when we're talking about glacier recession,
it's important to understand what the baseline is.
Our baseline in this case is the biggest.
The glaciers have been in 10,000 years.
And what's interesting,
and this is going on right now as the glaciers have been,
receding.
Geologists and biologists and and glaciologists and so forth have been studying
the landscapes that are being revealed as the ice shrinks back and you know,
what they're finding is the remains of forests that had been overrun by the
Little Ice Age glaciers up,
you know,
and and,
and peat bogs and things that would suggest that prior to the onset of the
little ice age,
those valleys that were filled with ice from roughly 1400 to 1800 were actually
forested because the ice came down and overran these forests and now it's
receding back and revealing that there were forests there.
So that tells you that,
you know,
at some point,
probably going back to the medieval warm period.
Those areas that were,
that have been glaciated during the early part of the 20th century were actually
of ice.
And so,
you know,
the climate has been extremely dynamic.
That's the thing we have to emphasize all by itself without any help from
humans.
And this is what I've been saying,
is that we have to look at that and realize that,
yeah,
humans are a factor.
You know,
somebody I did post and said all the other factors I had mentioned as you know,
ocean currents and wind currents and geomagnetic field and cosmic rays and
volcanism and all that.
It all been investigated in dismissed and the only thing left was the human
contribution.
But you know,
to me that's really.
We're putting all our eggs in that basket and that could turn out to be very
dangerous because we're so focused now on our own contribution that we might be
overlooking the fact that there have been natural factors driving climate change
over and over and over again.
I mean because I still have not heard any consensus on what has caused the
planet to first go into an ice age and come back out of an ice age.
And I think that what Graham and I are talking about actually presents a
possible solution to what could have brought this planet out of the Ice Age.
Something on a grand cosmic scale.
And the other point I think I'd like to make is that we have to really to
understand our planet as a system.
We have to realize that it's part of a cosmic ecosystem and the cosmos has been
a much bigger player in what's been going on down here then has been previously
understood or appreciated.
Yeah.